what's happened joy Coco D is here mad
flavors world going into a Joey karate
pick with [ __ ] my man Eddie Bravo I'm
just waiting for some late-breaking
he'll see when I do these pics do you
think I just sit at home and scratch my
balls no I make a few calls like well
Cleveland I called Boston I called a
couple of the campsite well cousin I'm
saying I send some mad flavor love on
Facebook and I try to figure out what's
really going on I would have eaten by
the baboon that's how I do it I don't
want you guys to think that Oh Joey's
anomalous I don't give a [ __ ] about rah
rah we're jumping up and down and
cheerleaders we do this to make a little
bit of [ __ ] scratch right or wrong
nah I'll even gamble I just try to help
you [ __ ] mooks because you're lost
you're running around I know what it is
to be 25 and ya get the money the
[ __ ] guy the money on Thursday and
you don't have it because you're betting
over your head you gamble for making a
little bit of [ __ ] scratch not for
walk around like Tony Montana 84 97
[ __ ] degrees and this broad is
walking around with [ __ ] goggles on
no one does she's [ __ ] single here
I'm saying it's hot out for the [ __ ]
bikini I'm walking down the street
you're [ __ ] look I'm just trying to
help [ __ ] hear them saying
we're these guys recon congestion this
[ __ ] guy pulls off without a blanket
talk stop [ __ ] people look at his
[ __ ] Mohammed Abdullah and North
Hollywood you see that got mad flavors
were you getting into my [ __ ] subtext
as I'm driving
don't say look at this [ __ ] thing he
just lies on fire [ __ ] I love this
[ __ ] joint look at this lady I'm a
[ __ ] cheeseburgers initiate today
what do you think
Gary Bravo represent tenth planet this
[ __ ] car here nice car huh
you parked this outside popeyes chicken
it's all lovely [ __ ] but the shop
somebody was getting [ __ ] stabbed I'm
saying beautiful [ __ ] right there's
my man Eddie I'm gonna figure this
[ __ ] cart out he usually eats he just
came back and taking pictures
[ __ ] jumping jacks where the [ __ ] he
does in the afternoon
and I was at home doing my thing so we
have five two [ __ ] look this up we do
this once a week and catch up with the
11 and he's the king of bad movies he
loves going through those [ __ ] movies
he gets the king of the bad movies I
always ask him how is that little bit
[ __ ]
check it out brother
an enchanted evening with Joey Diaz and
all the we're at Matt flavor world this
is how we roll
un-fuckin'-believable hey jiu-jitsu
he's a lover he's a [ __ ] fighter he
went to Brazil he knows how to play
Chariots of Fire look he's a [ __ ]
Savage Eddie let's go yeah also he knows
I play Chariots of Fire will Guzzi mad
flavor here joyed is talking about mad
flavors world I go out every [ __ ]
night to do comedy
aha cafe my girl Felicia Michaels and my
boy shows up here drop it drop the beat
on people is the real deal you said I
gotta put up with every night hey go you
need to just go out and crack jokes
I got Charlie beating box next to rob
Terry I'll be walking back the corner
what the [ __ ] is going on in my life
it's about 12 35 I gotta have about a 15
minutes ago I think this I washed my
hands I brushed my teeth
I ate a banana
points ain't emotional a couple buckets
I can't lie to you people you people
subscribe you know like what most people
away what are you doing man I went for
the hot - that don't work on a set from
no walk you so I could be sharp for you
[ __ ] savages when I got all they were
broken and I came home like I said that
was my night I was out I got that dirty
and I'm back through his way I do every
night if I don't go alone I stay on my
little bit if I'm gonna pick him up and
check why [ __ ] and kill myself I stand
home I got a bit of 10 I sleep but the
best thing when I come all business by
coming uptown look at this [ __ ] guy
tell me this guy I don't have the life
of Riley huh here's my man fit down on
one side of the couch my little pajamas
on I got my little flip-flops on that's
how I roll and that's my man stupid bed
on the other calf I got he must be
surviving he was dead anyway
anyway that's my night guys I don't give
up big deals there's nothing this is it
those days reward for more though strip
qualify for a couple counterfeit 20s and
they're [ __ ] fun I'm gonna giggle get
the [ __ ] outta you don't be if I do it a
felony why the [ __ ] go out where's my
client over the [ __ ] Republicans [ __ ]
you home this is it that flavor will
thank you for being a part of it stay
back